[موسيقى]
بخوف وحذر تهافه رجال الانقاذ لانتشاله
ليستقبلهم هو بضحكاته البريئه انه رضيع
الانقاض الضاحك ابن الستين يوما صمد امام
الزلزال المدمر وبقي تحت الركام لخمسه
ايام في انطاكيا التركيه وحين خرج للنور
تغلبت براءته على معاناته وضحك الرضيع
الضاحك شغل الجميع منذ لحظه نقله الى
المستشفى في مدينه اضنه التركيه بقي
الصغير تحت الانقاض لمده خمسه ايام ثم نقل
الى المستشفى بواسطه الاسعاف الجويه لكن
حالته العامه جيده فهو بخير الطفل الضاحك
مجهول الهويه لا يعرف اسمه ولم يتم التوصل
الى والديه حتى الان لكن الطاقم المستشفى
الذين يعملون جاهدين لرعايته اكدوا انه
سيبقى معهم بعد ان اسر قلوبهم بضحكاته
البريئه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه